pippo hallo sein crafter mensch wieder
alles klar
bei kraft catch me heißt es nochmal
kettchen schwester zu holen wie kann man
denn nur vergessen die welt kommt ist
bereit mein mann und ich habe ein tolles
wert verloren jedenfalls an meiner
letzten folge einen bosskampf gemacht
und jetzt geht's hier weiter gesprungen
klick before you go down okay was heißt
das jetzt antwort ich wette irgendwas
geht gleich in die luft ich kann und ich
auch die fackel nicht geändert haben es
auch nie samstag
ja das geht noch finde ich es geht noch
dieses gut erschlossen
guck mal das schaffe ich also noch aber
wenn er gleich länder oder kakteen du
bist auch mit sich sei froh ich wette du
fällst jetzt die lava wir haben dreimal
gegen stück zurück exchange respekt
geschäftsmann ja mal sein
ich war im trainingslager st jalloud
zuschaut gorilla dritten teil
also ich habe ich gestoppt gorilla was
ist denn jetzt passiert ach das ist
dieser dieser links auf das level checke
ich bin beim flugzeug wie kann das
angehen
ja das hatte ich auch und miri in
verbrannt ich brenne aber ich habe noch
meine kasse rückzug sondern was ich hab
netter stern ich muss nicht immer zu dir
worten irgendwie klappen checkpoint ich
weiß wie dapd
ich bin immer wieder beim flugzeug wenig
auf respawn clique komme ich immer
wieder oben bei dem flugzeug was wir in
folge 2 warten
das hatte ich aber auch schon bald wird
plötzlich habe ich bin dann mal metall
gestorben bist was du die kiste schon
geöffnet war ist nix drin weil ich die
schon geöffnet
ich bin schon weiter vorher wurde du was
komorowski hat auch nicht schlecht so
weiter sind wir wieder gegen decke
springen okay und ich war auf dem mond
klassenzimmer aufgefallen den mond
richtig tolle sache was damit hier
eincheckt vor wir auch ganz meinerseits
right click click ich mache ja variante
ohne klick ich glaube wir müssen das
kliniken wahrscheinlich kennedy klick
klick klick klick klick ich glaube die
kontrast an die gleiche idee die alle
momente herum hören
ddd titel halo crafter mensch da alles
klar
er geht so ich bin hier gerade noch bei
einem jump'n'run ja sollte dabei helfen
dabei einfach mal vorbeikommen immer
vorbei ist wird man das mal überlegt er
hätte böse wird packt er die pistole
walther dann packe ich meine pistole aus
der zeile durch den irland-hilfen hier
sind zwei wege ich bin es einfach irland
ja viele wege führen nach oben nicht
noch eine hüpf von einfach so im kreis
jetzt wieder zurück der jäger auf der
ver.di runtergefallen wegen dir ging mir
das ist aber schön hier ist es aber
schön
ok und jetzt schön mittel weiße ich
schieße immer extra an die wand wenn ich
jetzt mit meiner stern gefunden was die
djk aber wo müssen wir jetzt lange wir
kommen hier über diesen weg ganz
entspannt und jetzt bin ich jetzt
irgendwie benutzen wir gucken wo das
lange ich bin jetzt wieder bei dir oben
so dass der check personen mittlerweile
hier müssen schild markieren er habe ich
auch gesehen nein andere richtung heran
doch dann hier aktuell 4 grad schon
gelaufen
stimmt und da sind die schilder den weg
dahin müssen geschafft da steht auf den
schildern gibt es in japan tillieux
fingers bleed genua hms patrol insolvenz
auf diese köpfe drauf springen ja jetzt
theoretisch na ja ich bin wieder da
unten vorgespannt hat meine mutter ruft
mama ganz kurzen katja ich muss mein
nokia abnehmen wolle nokia das nokia
funktioniert
was sie da tun meine brust halten muss
werde ich kurz von ihrem der sauber das
geschafft ich bin so knapp wie darunter
gefallen immer wenn man meine eigenen
checkpoints bist du gerade aufnehmen
oder was ja oh hallo hallo unerwartet so
riet mir übrigens auch miteinander wenn
wir nicht aufnehmen so behindert
rad wieder zurück was los ist
wir sehen schon wir achten nicht auf
menschen mit tirol auf der karte das was
man machen muss
wo soll ich denn lang ich weiß nicht wo
ich hin muss ich will wieder zu diesem
jahr wird zum anfrage dass die tastatur
wurde schwarzeneggers da drin bist ganz
toll an ich bin ich bin super typ vier
stück von den oder 1000 oder so ok 4000
den kopf
die meisten sachen liebe was ich mache
ich hab jeden sprung noch mal einzeln
gerade geschafft ich doch auch halbes
herz
doch ich glaube es auch die sound einmal
nach ich stimme dir völlig vergessen so
auf 11 prozent
ich hab s geschafft genau da vorne bin
ich runter gefallen bei dem
und ich hoffe wenn man das schon mal
geschafft hat dann dahin fliegen ist es
kein schieden das ist meiner ansicht
nach so ach so der erklärung graf daten
ansichten
diese sprünge sind wir schon sehr
sympathischer sehr sympathisch ich habe
fehler gemacht ich glaube weil ich
springst du wieder runter
wahrscheinlich wollte ich dir auch
keiner wusste die hosen anhaben
das will ja gut dass du hast du linken
mit pinken schlüpfer an keine holst du
liest alter wo müssen wir jetzt mal
langweilig finde ich diese glocke sie
blenden auch alle die blenden wie deine
schönheit
sie bleiben denn wie deine chromfelgen
vielleicht auch eine gewisse
leichtigkeit die folge wendete er sollte
terrorrat berichten zufolge mit den
meisten seiner montagsausgabe
in felder waren schlecht sehr früh so
als beste was wir kriegen könnte dem
fall weil wir einfach schlecht ist auch
auf die beine stellen weil er den fall
schlecht in dem fall hoyzer einfach
wieder die gleichen weg runter
gesprungen
ohne scherz also boom ist weder lang ich
bin es im sport ich war gut dass wir
heute mal aufnahme phasen die phase
einfach nichts mehr geht
die sechsten folge haben stück auf dem
man so ja also wir sind jetzt hier rast
eine freudig über das zuerst mal das ist
schon richtig dass wir hier lang gehen
bitter auf weiter geht es einfach nicht
jedoch ist einfach richtig gut
es ist richtig wir müssen hier unten
landen doch der ging eher andersrum
das war einfach schon richtig wieso habe
ich mich dann auch umgebracht hatte
die rats ok wir sind ja sogar richtig
gut wir sind die profis stehen und jeder
der die map ansatzweise schon mal
gespielt hat weiß einfach schon die
lösung und sie einfach wie groß sind die
man sich später erst nach unserem video
sind die beiden einen bogen und grippe
sind wir müssen die rap der mann eng ein
iq-test irgendwie an eigene website wo
man die kuh testen ganz schick nein ein
unfallfreier websites inhaber an und
meinen wir sollen die guten eindruck
gibt hat man kann hier nicht hoch
echte hoch schlagen aber ich springe
nicht gut geklappt
als ich auch wieder wiederbeleben
gedrückt bekam kurz da musste gleich
nicht das ist wohl drauf geplant gab der
entwickler hat mich dabei gefahren
gedacht dass man dadurch nicht
hochkommen bestimmt immer da hat man hat
gedacht ich da warte ich mal ganz kurz
am audi die blockaden abbauen
ziemlich schnell egal ob ich zu mir ich
war auf dem blog drauf ich bin damit
hoch geflogen
hierüber zu springen so ja nicht diesen
button liebe mit checkpoint halter der
phoenix bringt red bulls duo even in the
project bleibt ihre gegner ist diesen
sogar drei hoch anstatt 2 oder ein
richtig korrekter typ der hersteller
denkt noch mal ums gehalt ist so der der
ball drin sind
in street parade ich meine
an sich ist die karte handelt die
eigentlich vom thron und normalerweise
was auf jeder apple gadget rollen
während des todes auf dieser karte
einfach will so gut vorankommen wollen
wir uns so gut wie gar nicht hey hey du
richtig dumm was war da was macht dieser
knopf ach man muss hochspringen alt her
bist du auch so hoch geflogen bin ich
älter werde mich gerade an die
allererste app die wir zusammen gespielt
hat weil es echt die ersten studierenden
darstellt doch das war die erste auf
seiner insel
ja das ist also ihr auch dass haustiere
kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor
und dann war obendrein es ist gleich in
ein kart und du hast taten gesagt bei
dem ein kart oder das macht so spaß hier
und du sagst alleine mike reid niemand
kann man noch die boote glaube ich oder
dann kam noch die bootstour indianer die
darunter die bootstour herrscht ein
brief an reilly war ich nutzen chip on
board trip hop special das kommt auf
twitter longboard uhr ok wer mit mehrere
ausgänge die wir wo wir lang gehen
können
ja wenn man dir welcher ist der richtige
frage ich bin guck mal keiner vorne raus
jemanden mit 7 dann kann auch das ich
finde einfach wieder den ganzen jacky
man kann einmal hier um jumpen warst du
schon mal der wollen neben
heruntergefallen und kann aber auch
währenddessen kuchen so completely
useless checkpoint und jetzt klar jetzt
machen wir hier jetzt kommen wir hier
ein laufen aber die müssen das war
später schon wieder runter gefallen
was sind das für sprünge hier ich weiß
nicht mitunter auch glaube ich ja da bin
ich auch immer gefallen aber ich glaube
nicht dass er lange müssen wir müssen
über diese clowns da oben ja ich glaube
beide wege fehlen hier sogar so ein
pfeil guck mal wieder rein als anteil
der so zur seite geht ach so will ich
wieder nicht über dich gefreut
kommunaler seite alles alles euro
damit gewann schade ich hatte ich auch
wie geht das
liebe dich
ich finds richtig cool immer mit dir das
aufzunehmen glaube immer ausbauen da
ihnen die so ganz viele creeper gar
keine ahnung wo wir herkommen und damit
ruhe gefunden
ludwig huber und jetzt ist der stern die
ablöse schleppend und damit den man dann
in der nächsten folge wieder weil die
vorgeschaltete ende was laut darauf habe
ich gehofft
wenn es euch gefallen hat diese
schießerei ja und dieser action coole
mal wieder bei dieser lockeren jumping
all der kleinen plattform höher
gesprengt alle überall fifa macht die
mal weg macht lieber weg und gemacht die
man aber mit einem nokia handy computer
im vertriebsweg über die mögen mein
handy so sehr deswegen sterben die
vorfreude ja cool ich glaube wir müssen
auf die leute oben na ja genau
wir werden diesen tagen wieder wenn wir
dann in die leider generiert ganz
weitergeht sehen wir dabei komme ich
habe noch mal eben kurz dass ich bei dir
bin und dann würde ich sagen es euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich sehr über
einen mag ich freuen
ich bin hier ich bin jetzt draußen bist
draußen dann laufe ich auch noch jemand
aus dem häuschen das war nicht wichtig
bin runter gefallen
ich bin dann über diese lebenden steine
nach rechts gesprungen da aus dem
fenster raus und dann kommt man da
irgendwie in das wasserbecken rein passt
eigentlich gewiss auf dem weg von hier
pass auf rufe weil er wegen mal war weil
hier unten weil er unter dir unternehmen
springst dir auf dann hier offen dann
geht es hier weiter
glaube ich also ich glaube es geht hier
weil man kann auch da oben eigentlich
die leitung da ist bestimmt noch einen
stern handy oder auch noch eine truhe
die haben gar nicht gesehen
egal ob als zufolge
dann sehen wir uns dann wieder da
solltet euch die längste verabschieden
die irgendwie gemacht habe haut rein und
schön mit